okay when we go ahead and get started we
welcome everyone to our Thursday de maiz
informatics conference and it's nice to
see such a full house today I know that
part of it is we have some distinguished
guests on campus which include five
individuals who are in the final stages
of interview for our funding in our PhD
program for our National Library
medicine training grant well the pizza
helps and get in the regular people here
anyways so and also as with all these
talks it's being streamed over the
internet we made a little effort to kind
of get the word out and as we always do
we'll have any remote people who want to
answer who want to ask questions to just
tweet at us with the hashtag demise comp
the mi SI e conf our topic today is
about an initiative that's been going on
in the department for a couple years now
and I believe it's a very important
initiative and I think it represents the
way that academia is changing no longer
can we be isolated hunkered down in our
research grants publishing papers and
not interacting with the rest of the
world and so Aaron Cohen while
introduced in a moment has really been
the force developing the idea of the
informatics discovery lab aided by deb
Woodcock and we are already starting to
see a number of successes of this
initiative and I think it's important
for faculty to provide more
opportunities for our students not who
not in large numbers will sort of follow
our phenotype of becoming academic
faculty or at least the traditional
academic faculty phenotype so I won't
take too much more variance time but
just
to introduce Aaron those of you here
know him dr. Cohen is an associate
professor in the department is also
director of the informatics discovery
lab which is going to talk about he
obtained his most of his education at
the University of Michigan degree in
engineering and also medical degree went
off on a more of a software engineering
path ended up at Intel and about 10
years ago ended up in my office wanting
to return to his medical roots and he
became actually speaking of NLM training
grants became a postdoctoral fellow was
very successful has a very successful
research career in areas of text mining
and machine learning applied to a
variety of medical areas and continues
that work but also carries does the work
of the informatics discovery lab he's
going to start the talk and then he's
going to introduce to others who will
also take part in the talk Deb Woodcock
and Nicole weisskopf one of our new
faculty so i will stop talking at this
point so thanks Bill that was really
nice introduction he did it off the top
of his head which is impressive yeah so
I'm going to start and then we're going
to do a little bit of tag team thing
with Deb and Nicole talk about the state
of the ID ality informatics discovery
labs so you know why are we here today
well perhaps some of you are asking some
of these questions we know that some of
you have been maybe all of you about the
informatics discovery lab what's it all
about what is this thing what do we do
why do we have such a thing some of you
know a little bit about it's like well
how can I get involved what is the I IDL
mean for students in the department so
I'm going to go through some of this
we're going to we're going to talk about
both the sort of ID and concept of the
IDL and what our core values and goals
are and
talk a little bit about specific things
that we're doing and have done to give
you kind of a flavor of the work and
then talk about plans for the next year
and try to directly address how people
can get involved and where the
connections are between the students and
the faculty and the rest of the
community and the IDL so what's the idea
so the ideal is an initiative of the
department of the medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology which i'll
just say d my so not to read all that it
anymore today so it's wholly a part of
the department's not a separate thing
from the department its initiative
within the department which also means
that it's not all of the department the
IPL is not responsible for every
possible thing that comes up not every
single crazy idea that the faculty and
other people come up will be an IDL idea
some of those crazy ideas will be ideal
at the ideas but not every single one
and so which crazy ideas well the ones
that are focused on creating
collaborations with partners who are
non-traditional now you know I've
struggled over over the time of the IDL
for what term to use here
non-traditional so what we mean by that
is not the people that academic
implementations traditionally at least
here collaborate with so you know every
grant proposal that goes to the NLM I
would call that traditional okay so
non-traditional is reaching out to you
know operational groups within the
health system or other health systems or
startup companies working while working
in health IT or major companies who need
some kind of informatics expertise or we
have a certain kind of expertise that
maybe could complement some of the
capacity they have those are kinds of
things I'm thinking or non-traditional
also you know skirt the gray line a bit
and call like sbirs and sttr s which are
small business startup and development
grants is nontraditional it's not
something that we've traditionally done
a lot of in this department so our
wordly oriented meaning that we we have
stuff that we're good at we have things
that were valuable we think are valuable
in terms of active
informatics may be that we think are
valuable in terms of the quality of how
information is used out in the real
world and we want to get that out there
we want we want good informatics to be
to be deployed out into the world and
not just something that uses a computer
and has medical data and as quote
unquote called informatics so who's the
IDL so I stole the picture up there from
the department website not that every
single person in this picture has played
a direct role in the IDL but many of
them have some of the people in here are
in prime arilinn department some are
related to department but potentially
everybody in the department may play a
role with the IDL as the right
opportunities come up in the right and a
right circumstances I'm obviously the
director and Deborah Cox the program
manager we have an ideal leadership team
that very much functions kind of like an
advisory board and it's made of faculty
from the department and outside the
department and there's been some flow in
and out as different opportunities have
arisen or different focus areas have
arisen and so we've added some people
and maybe some people necessarily
haven't dropped off but maybe have been
a little less focused on the ideal for
different periods of time so you know
one of the things that we want to do and
I don't want to get up it had too much
but you know I leash is added to the to
the IDL leadership team because we
really want to have more interdigitating
with the BCB track and so to facilitate
that we've got some ideas already about
that that are going to go forward so the
the leadership team is is is fluid
depending on what the circumstances are
going on and other ohsu faculty and
staff lots of people I won't read
everybody's name but it's involved with
projects right so we cannot the IDL is a
as a fixed set of resources is pretty
small we're not going to do everything
all by ourselves part of the
collaboration is collaborating with the
faculty and
and staff and students in the department
as the opportunities arise that fit
those outward goals that we talked about
so why do we have an idea dev laughed
when I put this in here because but I
you know I think it's really true you
know we've got an interesting you know
explosion going on where commercial EHRs
are just exploding everywhere right I
mean we're going to talk a little bit in
the future about the DoD converting from
its homegrown system to picking choosing
a commercial EHR so you know EHRs have
hit the big time these are big
commercial products and big commercial
products need expertise and resources
and management and people that know how
to apply these things in productive ways
at the same time the homegrown systems
that maybe have been the traditional
basis of a lot of academic informatics
research are really going away I mean to
be honest they're not just decreasing I
mean most of the places you know Harvard
and an inner mountain isn't her Mac he
remembers Intermountain switching to
aren't they there yeah so they're
basically all the homegrown systems are
going all right so we can have a long
conversation about why the homegrown
systems are going away for being my
software engineering background I just
see this is an inevitable software
maintenance problem you know there's
just no you can't amortize the
maintenance and support across all the
different installations if it's just
your homegrown system at your
installation and you know I hospital
systems for the most part and even
research institutions you know they're
not commercial software vendors they're
not their academic institutions so
they're what they're good at and we'll
talk about this in a minute is different
so it makes sort of sense but um while
this is happening you might think oh
well this is bad for academic
informatics because you're losing
control over these homegrown systems
what are you going to do but actually i
think this sort of an explosion of
expectations and for what the EHR can do
and things related to the EHR let's just
say electronic health information in
general and the
expectations and the opportunities for
really making an impact our are huge now
though that impact is going to somehow
be connected or work through these
commercial EHRs as a platform but
there's more opportunity in informatics
to affect you know health and health
research than there ever has been right
so that's what I mean by this by this
nuclear explosion kind of thing now the
opportunities like bill was alluding to
the opportunities aren't necessarily all
classical traditional infirmity shin
you're going to get a faculty position
somewhere in write grants to do
particular research but there are
incredible opportunities sort of in that
in that interface between applying
commercial commercial systems and and
really making them them work well and
rigorously that's why I've got the word
rigorous in here you know it's it's one
thing to just calculate numbers it's
another to to apply rigorous informatics
to make sure that those numbers are
meaningful and actionable right so I
alluded to this before that I i think
that there's really good this really a
good time for synergy I've shown this
slide before people heard ID I'll talk
stood and I'm not going to go into
reading all the little things but the
main point of this is that academia is
very good at certain things academia is
good a trigger academia is good at
evaluation of decade mu is good at
thinking out of the box academics good
at thinking maybe a little bit more long
term you know between well while
corporations may have to think about you
know the next quarters profits or
something on the other hand academia is
bad at some things like long-term
support and maintenance and things like
that that industry is really good at
right managing customers and and and
delivering value and slung term support
for those customers that they can depend
upon and so there's really a lot of
space I think in the collaboration
between these two groups in order to do
things that really can't be done singly
by either group but this points out you
know that there are a lot of
opportunities in combining these
complementary strengths but you know
what do you need to do
succeed in this well we need to develop
you know competencies that we don't
necessarily traditionally have an
academia or at least we don't have
widely in academic i will say that there
are some academic institutions in some
areas that are really good at this so
the two that come to mind are you know
stanford with their computer science
which is incredibly interdigitated with
palo alto about you know everything and
you know and the sort of MIT area in the
media lab and the media lab was kind of
the original inspiration for the
discovery lab you know we wanted to have
some environment where there was
continuous interplay between these you
know industry non-traditional partners
and and academia so how do you do that
well we have to develop new kinds of
competencies right we need to develop
competencies in building new kinds of
relationships that are different than
your academic collaborators or the
program officer at the nih different
timing and timelines and expectations in
terms of how fast things move and how
how how you budget for things and and
just a whole different idea of time
scale different types of contracts and
agreements believe it or not a contract
is not a contract in places like OHS you
are very good at managing certain kinds
of relationships and certain kinds of
contracts and other kinds of things look
weird and they don't necessarily know
what to do with them so we have to
educate ourselves as well as the
organization and how to do these things
in a fluid manner and this is sort of an
ongoing learning process as you develop
relationships with with partners
companies and figure out under what kind
of terms are they willing to work and if
those terms work for us and then how do
you get the university to you know
understand and i just didn't approve
that in a way right because we're still
we're not going around any of the
processes in the universe we still have
to go through the grants and contracts
office and follow all the rules and
everything like that right we're not
sort of some kind of independent you
know Wild West kind of entity we still
have to follow the rules but sometimes
understanding the rules and what can be
done and
I kind of push the envelope of what's
okay is a learning process different
types of project management and
reporting you know just from my and
there's a huge this is a huge space and
we're not going to go into it a whole
lot but you know the way you manage your
research grants probably doesn't apply
to some kind of commercial deliverable
that well and so there's that's a big
space you know a project management
software project management there's a
lot of different tools and techniques
and approaches you know that the other
people are more expert than I am but
that we need to develop appropriate
compensation order to do that and of
course you know intellectual property
concerns right how do you how do you
share intellectual property who
developed a wat who's bringing what's at
the table how do you get something out
of that one of the things we'd really
like to do in the IDL is develop more
you know uses as a vehicle to develop
more intellectual property but also get
that intellectual property out there to
improve health and health care research
and so how do you manage that how do you
make those relationships with it we have
you know ongoing discussions with a
number of companies and I will tell you
that their intellectual property
concerns are one of the big things and
and I think one of the reasons we've
been successful is that we take those
things seriously so you know if they're
giving us some technology there has to
be some sort of understanding in terms
of what is just sort of tweaking that
technology a little bit really isn't new
intellectual property that really that
company still owns versus something
really new and novel that we can
contribute that maybe uses that
technology in some way but is really a
new thing there's no on top or connected
on the side of that and being able to to
work out those agreements so that
expectations are clear is is a big deal
the companies are not just going to give
you something and say here do whatever
you want with it because that's going to
put them at a lot of risk and what they
want to do is minimize their risk and
exposure and you have to be sensitive to
that it may seem like low low risk to us
that something's really going to happen
but you know it might be low likelihood
but big impact and that means it's
important to them and so we have to take
it seriously so probably no talk that
involves Deb in any way would be
acceptable without a Dilbert cartoon
I'll just I'll just do you usually read
your Dilbert cartoons I don't usually
sell ok so the junior engineer says to
Dilbert a 27 year old tech millionaire
published as list of 50 things you need
to do to succeed I don't know what this
theme of 50 is but 50 in other words is
in other words he has no idea why
succeeded oh sure he does even as a
chart of his top 30 priorities ok I hear
it now so obviously this is being
sarcastic right you can't focus on 50 or
30 different things focus is incredibly
important if you want to be successful
you have to decide what you're going to
do and what you're going to be good at
what you're not going to do and you have
to have some idea of what you know what
what you could be successful at what you
can put your energies at all right if if
you if you have to focus on 50 or 30
different things and being good at all
of them you're going to be good at none
of them right so you know with that the
aims of the IDL are to make the most of
this this opportunity this this
opportunity to collaborate in this in
this new time in this in this new way
and so the things that we really want to
achieve are establishing long-term
partnerships I already mentioned this
deploying rigorous informatics into the
wild you know into the real world that
really takes care of patients or does
real real real research clinical and
bench research enhance the scope of
education and training and what I mean
by that is both for faculty and students
provide exposure to learning experiences
primarily non-classroom on structured
learning experiences but learning
experience practical learning
experiences that they that they wouldn't
have otherwise so you know for student
having some exposure in in something
related to
operations and how informatics really
impacts the real world and an
operational sense for faculty the idea
that they can take some of their
expertise or some of the research and
apply it to a real world problem that
has you know significant value to to one
of one of our partners lead you know
that's what the bill was talking about
the IDL being sort of the providing a
certain leadership in the department for
the new direction and what we think is
really important is to establish both
this collaborative mindset where we're
always looking for collaborative
opportunities it's sort of for lack of a
better phrase fire on multiple cylinders
in other words meet multiple goals and
are good to do for many different
reasons and create this more
entrepreneurial culture because you know
like like bill was saying and I've said
before you're not all going to become
academic infirmity shins right I bet you
in 20 years more of you wind up being
entrepreneurs hopefully successfully
than academic infirmity shins because
that's just where the opportunities are
right there incredible numbers of
opportunities to change things with with
both good informatics but but also you
know as somewhat more business mindset
about how to solve problems that deliver
value and we need to think about that
right there's it's certainly I'm not
putting down academic informatics I
think knowledge for knowledge akin this
time and so we should balance that with
with how to apply that knowledge to
deliver you know meaningful value value
doesn't necessarily mean money it might
just mean better health care outcomes or
it might just mean you know better
better patient experience or or spending
less money to figure out some new cure
or what works or what doesn't work or
just getting the right information to
the right person at the right time in a
more pleasant you know way so you you
can define value you know however you
want that but you need to evaluate
things against against some kind of
value yardstick and lastly and not last
in importance but you know diversify
funding sources right to be
festival acted academic informatics
department I think we're going to have
to have these mix of collaborative
funding sources right right now that the
funding and the department I don't think
this is a big secret bill you know is
like education is like this and reading
research right research grants are like
this and everything else is like this
and we need to spread that out more so
we have more diversified funding both so
we can both because it will be a natural
consequence of these collaborations and
deploying things out into the real world
but also just you know like anything
else is weird of diversifying our
portfolio like you would in the stock
market or anything else we want to be in
all the quote unquote informatics
markets that we think we can play in
well okay so I'm going to switch gears a
little bit that's sort of the philosophy
of the IDL and why we're here and what
we're doing or what how we think about
what we're doing i'll talk a little bit
about what we've been doing so Deb and I
were talking about how to how to present
this a little bit and I of course made a
laundry list and she made it a little
bit better it's organized into sort of
foundational things initial wins over
the first couple of years and then stuff
that's on this with horizon stuff that
we're looking at in the near future of
doing so you know we've got we've moved
it probably most of you know we have our
offices in the South Waterfront we're a
little bit suffered from the department
I don't think the intention was so much
to separate from the department as much
as have a space we could call the IDL we
could meet with commercial entities and
other partners they can come down to the
space it's actually a pretty nice space
as nice wood paddling and stuff like
that it's just a little bit more
comfortable kind of place to to meet so
so we have that we've not established a
number of relationships with key
collaborators which I'll talk about in a
minute we have a successful faculty
recruitment right we have Nicole who is
going to talk it in a little bit Nicole
weisskopf is a system professor that we
recruited from Columbia so that's a
great big win and we're
putting we have in place right now and
you'll hear about this more epic
training for D mice researchers we've
we've actually got so another thing it's
not on the list I guess that should have
we have brought up as part of the epic
partnership research and educational
instances of epic that I don't have any
live patient data but have the full ohsu
build on them and run separately from
the clinical system and so the
educational system is used to actually
deliver the clinical information systems
lab course so that the people that are
taking that lab course get some hands-on
epic experience and the research system
the intention is to let researchers use
that system to whatever it is configure
screens create smart forms come use epic
api's for data interfaces or whatever it
is that would facilitate their research
and we're putting together this training
program and essentially get the
researchers and I think we're going to
open this up two fellows up to speed on
being able to use it for that so these
instances are up and running the
educational instance has been used twice
already that the course has been run
very successful as far as I know by
Vishnu for two semesters and I think
next will be either summer fall the
research inches is up and running we've
used it lightly we haven't used it as
much as I would like to but part of that
is bringing the faculty up to speed so
they can use it effectively initial wins
so you know just to finish off talking
about the epic partnership we are as far
as i know we are certainly the first and
as far as I know the only academic
informatics department in the world
having a formal relationship with epic
to use to use their system in research
in informatics education so there may be
some other people doing this illegally
without epics approval I don't know but
we have their approval to do this and
we've got a whole sort of process in
place for how we communicate with them
and
both let them know how things are going
what parts of the system are using and
that kind of stuff Casey VI partnership
we're going to talk a lot nicole's going
to talk a lot more about this has to do
with casey VI really wants to be a
leader a top ten cardiovascular
institute and there's big commitment
from the leadership there to use a
data-driven decision making to do this
so what they need is help with putting
up an analytics platform a data
analytics platform for seeing how
they're doing making process changes
testing those process changes by
monitoring the data etc and Nicole taco
that gives you some examples about some
of the details of that other things
organ health authority clinical quality
measures registry we've been giving this
primarily led by David door giving
advice basically for how they would
create that based on strong informatics
principles we spot we organize sponsored
in one you probably already know this
the 2014 Amy a student design challenge
were deaf led that group and they did a
really bang-up job about that and we're
going to try to win again next year so
if you guys are interested double give
another plug for that we've done over
the last year IDL industry leader talks
where we have brought in a number of
industry leaders in the health IT space
from both large and small companies I
think something we'd like to focus on
more and more is more entrepreneurs more
some oral small companies more startup
kind of people we've had some of them in
and this is part of creating a trip
renew your culture and also just you
know educating people in terms of in
terms of what do you do to be an
entrepreneur you know what are the steps
how do you get something up and running
it's it's a lot different than writing a
research grant or a paper on the horizon
so talk a little bit more about the epic
DOD proposal which were part of I
mentioned it earlier that they're
converting over to a commercial EHR we
are putting in place mechanisms to
collaborate more
more closely by establishing basically
some regular meetings and and the
teasing out specific projects that
clinical informatics and the IDL could
collaborate with and that's certainly an
opportunity that that faculty and
students could participate in Jeff
golden Vishnu with a little bit of help
from the IDL have participated in an
SBIR that has to do with tablet tablet
based interfaces for the ICU and we
talked about the wanting to do the
student design challenge next so just a
little introduction to the night
cardiovascular I think I already said a
lot of this they want to enhance the
quality in a workflow with analytics and
they're going to do this using sort of a
gnat form to continuously and
automatically computes quality measures
in order to give them good data to
become a top ten cardiac institute these
measures are not just going to be
numbers but they're going to be
monitored and visualized using tableau
which is essentially a data exploration
visualization package that has a lot of
nice both both visualization GUI and as
well as public publishing features it's
also got like a web server so people can
just go to the page and see the latest
numbers kind of thing and as will found
and maybe Nicole will touch on this it's
very much of a team driven agile process
you uncover all kinds of things that you
wish you had known when you started but
there was no way for you to know until
you dig into it and so it's really been
a I think I'm mutually rewarding and
intellectually stimulating process to
work with the case evi cardiology
experts and digging into what it really
takes two to get meaningful quality
measure numbers that can be used to make
decisions and I think the next life is
yours so so I'm going to shut up for a
few minutes and let Michael talk oh and
I got it oh you got it okay
does this one on ok so we're I'm
actually going to go out of order
slightly ok so a lot of what we've been
working on with the kc VI project is
taking a set of performance measures
from the acc the American College of
Cardiology and implementing them in a
way that they are going to continuously
update over time and this will be a way
that kcv I can actually track their
performance these are mostly process
measures but process measures are
ultimately clinically meaningful in the
hope is that by monitoring their
performance they can actually improve
performance as well as benchmark
compared to the rest of the country to
other institutions and see how they're
doing on these basic measures so this is
the first of the ACC measures and is the
percentage of out patients who are at
least 18 with a diagnosis of heart
failure who have had a quantitative or
qualitative result of an lvef which is
left ventricular ejection fraction is
usually done as part of an echo
documented within a 12-month period so
the idea is that anyone with heart
failure should have this basic
laboratory result documented in some way
every year it doesn't mean they need an
entirely new test but it means that
there needs to be a specific value or
qualitative value so good function
medium function that has to be evaluated
so what we've done at this point is we
have mapped the variables in epic that
are involved in this information so
structured laboratory results patient
diagnosis patient age and we have set up
a series of queries denominator
enumerator queries and if you just look
at the data that we get out
automatically it looks like KC VI is
operating at about sixty nine percent
performance on this very basic metric
that would be a very simplistic approach
that's where a lot of people would stop
this is where we can bring in our
expertise in fermentations because the
thing is nobody is going to trust a
number that says sixty-nine percent they
all know that they're due
than that so we've done a bunch of chart
review very in depth chart review and
what we can find is actually they're
operating at about ninety seven percent
and then the next step is we can go in
and we can find out where are the
failures and the processes that are
preventing us from getting at this
information a lot of it has to do with
workflow and documentation so for
example a lot of the patients that come
to kc VI are not actually Casey VI
patients they're seen somewhere else so
maybe they have an external echo and
that echo is not getting into our system
in a way that we can access it in an
automated way sometimes we even have
internal echoes and we can pull up the
report but nobody is actually entering
that lvef value into the structured data
again that's something that could very
easily be solved but we wouldn't know
that unless we had done this very
in-depth analysis so that's what we can
bring to this partnership what's been
very cool for me is also seeing what we
can get out of it what do we learn in
the process of doing this kind of
non-traditional work that is valuable to
us as academics and one thing that we
realize in the process of trying to
implement and evaluate these measures is
that there's no real process for doing
this it seems like a fairly
straightforward thing to do you decide
what you want to measure you identify
the right variables and fields and then
you write your queries and you're done
there are actually a lot more steps
involved and what we've realized is if
we can create a process for this and
validate it that's actually going to be
extremely valuable for the informatics
community and also clinical communities
so this process of actually measuring
performance is becoming more and more
important nationally so if we do
something like this we're actually
filling a fairly major knowledge gap so
it's really kind of a two-way street and
that's been part of what's so
interesting about doing this kind of
non-traditional work
so I already said all this about the
epic stuff so I'm just going to flash it
up there to remind you I'm will just go
on talk a little bit about about the DoD
so the IDL in the department are part of
this huge very competitive several
billion dollar proposal to replace the
DoD's homegrown EHR with some commercial
EHR and there's several different teams
I can't remember them off top of my head
but we are part of the IBM epic team and
we're basically the only academic
partner in this proposal we don't know
what the other proposals look like so we
don't know if they have academic
partners or not but we're the academic
partner for the for the IBM epic team
and we are the only academic partner for
that team what we focused on is really a
spin-off if you will of Jeff golden fish
news work on simulation based evaluation
and training and our role is to provide
simulation-based training to the DoD
clinical champions as they are deploy
starting to deploy and test this system
in across the DoD health institutions
there's also quite a bit of potential to
expand this work I guess I mean where
this is something we're learning some
competencies that we're developing but
there are I guess there's a long
tradition of additional work that comes
up related to contracts that also
require bidding and and and whatnot and
there is you know with the with the
great simulation lab that we have and
with the experts that we have in terms
of using the simulation lab for
usability analysis as well as as well as
training there's just a lot of
opportunity in that space especially in
a in a large deployment in in a varied
in challenging healthcare system like
the DoD so we just heard this week that
the there are three three groups left i
guess and and IBM epic / ohsu is one of
them and i guess we're thing
in early March there may be a decision
although you know its government and so
they they take their time they'll decide
when they decide so so what are the key
learnings that we've had in running the
ideal for I guess a couple of years
certainly partnerships are built on
relationships people don't sign
contracts and hand you their technology
or their money on the first date so to
speak it takes a lot it takes quite a
bit of time to develop these
relationship with a certain amount of
trust and mutual respect that has to be
developed already mentioned about
concerns about intellectual property and
that kind of thing and those have to be
addressed and you know both parties have
to figure that this is somebody I want
to actually work with environment and
culture matter right a lot of
opportunities kind of happen
serendipitously and you kind of have to
be looking for that at the same token
you can't do everything and so you have
to at least I look at opportunities is
like how many cylinders do they fire on
how many different success points do
they hit so I mean a great example of
this is the is the student design
challenge right we had that we had Marty
drezna come to us and say that she had
this this interesting this interesting
problem that had to do with children
drawing on an iPad app and was there
some way we could help her and
informatics and it very soon after that
Amy announced their student design
challenge and like that man I put these
two things together so that is a really
good project for a student design tool
obviously it was a really good project
because they won their won the challenge
but looking for those kind of
opportunities and building a culture
where that's sort of a regular and good
thing is really important similarly or
the other side of this what I've already
said prioritizing and balance are
essential right how do you focus on
doing the things that you're really
likely to be successful after you really
think you can do well and the stuff you
don't think you can be so the good what
don't bother some of our best turn that
traditional partner non-traditional
partners are quite close by like kcv I
like the discussions we're having with
the clinical informatics group and they
they have projects and things that they
can't quite get to that might be good
sort of combined
practical and research II kinds of
projects delivering value is important
maybe this should be the first thing
right you know utility scholarship value
these things need to co-exist but if
you're not delivering value in this
space people are less concerned about
the the pure intellectual part of it I
mean yes it's may be intellectually
interesting but it also has to deliver
value actionable value in some way and
that has to be a constant consideration
I mean there there's nothing wrong with
knowledge for knowledge sake but that's
not the area that we're playing in the
IDL we're card play hard I think that
we're I don't have that much to say
about it except that doing a good job is
important you know if you say you're
going to do something you need to do it
or have a really good reason why and
that reason why should be external not
because you've decided that to do it it
should be like it's impossible the data
doesn't exist or something like that and
we're very much looking forward to the
opening of the bridge you know the
people bridge which is basically right
behind us because there's some very good
brew pubs that are just right across the
river there so so what's on the plan for
the coming year we're going through a
strategic planning process planning and
budgeting right planning decide what's
important what we really need to do and
want to do and budgeting how are you
going to actually allocate the resources
to make that happen so things that we
have underway create strong ties to the
Portland health IT startup community we
want to have some formal very productive
interactive relationship with the health
IT startup community in Portland bill
and I have both thought for many years
building many more years than I have
that day Portland should really be a hub
of health IT you know we'll let will let
Seattle have microsoft and office apps
and stuff but we really think that we
could do something special and health IT
here so we're going to try to make that
happen deliver value to the University
you know both with KCCI projects and our
emerging relationship with clinical
informatics and other groups that we
have to keep our eyes open for that we
haven't
mat or discovered yet increased student
faculty engagement that's going to talk
about that in a minute work smarter with
more agility right we need to be able to
a lot of these projects they're not as
cut and dry as maybe some projects that
we're used to and so you know how do you
respond Anjali change priorities as as
priorities change your focuses
priorities change and how can we support
that with better processes and better
tools so that we put most of the energy
and the actual work and not in the
organization or management than that
kind of thing and one of the things that
we've brought up for the kc VI project
is essentially an issue and change
tracking tool the deb built on top of
sharepoint that we're using basically is
like an accessory brain right there's
just too many things going on a lot of
things that happen we're not going to
deal with with right now you know we
have to make a decision we're going to
do it this way right now but we need to
revisit it well you know an electronic
tool is a great way to do that and save
your cognitive mind space that you have
to keep all this stuff in your head
which is impossible for anybody so it's
in the list it pops up with the dates
like oh yeah we're supposed to think
about this again right now and so it
becomes much more easy to do and we want
to make significant progress toward
fiscal sustainability that means
bringing in as much or more revenue than
then we spend there is some aspect of
you know it takes some amount investment
right in time and people in order to
bring in this business in these
relationships but come up with more of a
model that's sustainable on a continuing
basis and how to do that now that that
said you know maybe one of the most
obvious ways of doing this is is having
continuing relationships with some of
your best partners where it's you know
it's not like it's not like the grant
ends like an hour 21 after two years and
you got to get another one it could be a
continuing relationship you know what
can we do for you next kind of thing so
the next couple of slides I think our
dabs just going to talk right want me to
talk about this one okay so def Encana
talk about the next slide I'm going to
talk about this slide so we kind of see
our our audience in three main groups
excuse me if I left anybody out but
students faculty and industry and
entrepreneurs and so kind of the plans
or what we're thinking about in terms of
students participate in IDL sponsored
projects that you'll hear more about
these could be capstones or internships
that were we're going to define and host
within the IDL also the student design
challenge that we're talking about other
design challenges that may come along
you know bring ideas for projects
especially ones that have some
commercialization potential some some
significant IP aspect because one of the
about it in here but one of the other
things that we've done is build a good
working relationship with tech transfer
business development in terms of high at
the University in terms of how we would
actually get stuff out because they're
the people responsible for for
negotiating those contracts in the terms
of those agreements
sure I mean a lot of this kind of thing
you know is like the ideas require some
exploring and poking on and maybe maybe
it is a commercially valuable idea maybe
it's not maybe with a little tweaking it
could be or maybe the way the customer
base you've been thinking about isn't as
good as some other customer base that
might use that idea so faculty right
proposed research opportunities use the
EHR the the epic research instance in
your research put it into one of your
grants if you wish collaborate with
industry you know I mean make your own
context and bring them into the IDL
Vishnu and Jeff have done that think
about becoming an entrepreneur if
there's something that you always wanted
to do that you think has some commercial
viability come talk to us about it
people who are already entrepreneurs in
industry you know you may have some
challenging problems or some some
knowledge gaps we're collaborating the
IDL can facilitate the collaboration
with specific faculty certainly sponsor
an internship or a challenge that we do
that you know has exposure in the wild
while wider world the ami a design
challenge or something like this and
certainly come and give us an ID I'll
talk you know provide the faculty and
the students in the community your
perspective on you know what the where
the markets going with what the
opportunities are what it takes to be an
entrepreneur how do you take a good idea
and turn it into a company these are all
things that we're trying to learn and
provide some kind of exposure to to the
community and the students so you're the
next slide which i think is the last
slide really
Thank You Erin so again a little bit of
a deep dive just as Nicole did into the
kcb I project I wanted to talk a little
bit more about this idea of student and
faculty engagement and we know that
there's interest and I know that we know
that Nicole met with the fellows when
did you have that meeting was that
during the fall do you remember yeah to
find out a little bit about more about
their interest in the IDL and how they
can become involved so really i would
say that we as aaron said have
identified this as a really key area
that we need to put some focus on for
the new year we've over the last two
years gone from basically Aaron and
myself working pretty closely on just
about every aspect of the IDL to
bringing in Nicole to bringing in FISA
to bringing in Elizabeth and so is we're
expanding we both are growing need for
involvement as well as capacity for
involvement and so I think the
overarching message is as Aaron said on
the previous slide we welcome your
involvement we want to hear what you're
thinking about we would like to know how
the lab can benefit you and we'd love to
be able to share with you ways that you
could benefit us and I think there are a
lot of areas in which we can do that so
one is Aaron is mentioned as a student
design challenge model which worked
pretty well last year this year I
understand we're going to take a
slightly different approach which is
there's still some sort of recruitment
going on in an organic way but I believe
that a leash and Shannon are working
together to facilitate for alicia's
research methods class in the spring to
use a challenge as a project actually so
if you're going to be involved in that
course you will be I think de facto
involved in the challenge in some way
but if you're not and you're interested
please come and talk to me or send me a
note we're going to have an organizing
meeting on this next week we already
have had some folks come forward with
different kinds of projects that we
might be able to do some from within
this faculty some from without without
the department and I think there's some
really interesting and exciting
ideas people who are interested in
participating are also welcome to bring
their own project ideas to the team so
we'll we'll discuss it decide what as a
group we want to work on maybe have even
more than one team a lot of different
ways we could skin that cat so we'll
look at that the other thing is Aaron
mentioned is that a lot of these
projects whether they're generated from
within the department or from within
clinical informatics in the hospital or
externally to ohsu could be used as
great capstone or thesis or internship
projects and so we're looking to build a
better framework for both taking in and
curating those opportunities and then
giving you a tool that you can use to
search and so I'm looking at Justin
right now because right now for his
databases class I'm working on something
called Project truffle because as some
of you know I'm a master student in the
program as well and it's always a
challenge to try to sniff out those
projects that align nicely with what
your academic interests are and that
also do what the second bullet point
there says he'll two birds with one
stone and this is what Aaron was
referring to also in terms of firing on
more cylinders if you can do a student
project you know assume that everything
Ithaca Lee lines up you can do a student
project that also is an ideal project
finding those those areas of overlap can
be very beneficial to both to both you
and to the department the IDL so I'd
like to view this as an opening of but
daya formal welcome and opening of
dialogue with all of you one of the
things Nicole and I who are going to be
focusing on this next year we're talking
about is you know whether we want to
start something with something very
lightweight like just a regular coffee
you know or happy hour where anybody's
interested in what's going on the ideal
we can get together we can talk about
what's going on if you've got projects
that you're thinking about bringing to
the IDL it would be an opportunity for
you to share that information and
obviously is as Aaron noted earlier if
you do get involved with one of the
projects that we have there would be a
more formal way of staying integrated
and staying involved but we would love
to hear from you and please feel free to
reach out to Nicole or myself at any
time with any ideas that you may have
Oh dined us anything nope that's it next
thing is this question yeah let minutes
for questions that arose oh yeah oh yeah
push the button see question for any of
us for any of the three of us or
whatever but I'll be the point person
anybody have questions comments answered
everything you could possibly want to
know so if you're not going to give
questions i'm going to put back my
soapbox down a little bit i think you
know the firing of multiple cylinders
thing is really is really important
right so the thing that's going to make
is different about doing a project with
the ideal is this delivery of value to
some customer right so that's going to
be a great opportunity for certain
students that want that experience and
want to be able to take that out into
the marketplace or whatever I did this
for this people and I did it in this way
um might not be as good a match for
somebody who's interested in something
maybe more esoterica wants to use their
master's program is a way to do kind of
an intellectual deep dive for something
you know I mean which is fine right but
that this is not a great match for the
IDL so you know thinking about what what
how there can be sort of that mutual
value is something I would just suggest
that you do while you're thinking about
ideas that might be it might be good
things to talk about you have any
questions bill always has a question oh
wait there's a question there go ahead
push the button Oh who's like come on if
I'm pushing her prove unless it's burned
out okay I've lost you hi so my name is
Emil I'm a recent Portland aight having
moved here from Cleveland and I'm on
staff IT staff at Case Western Reserve
University
I've been attending meetups and so forth
so this is directed towards your kind of
entrepreneurial area I've already
encountered you know close to a dozen
people in town who have some background
in statistics some background in science
but they're really kind of lacking
direction you talked about focus and and
that's clearly the kind of thing that
that people in the community who have
skills that are near to informatics you
know could could use a hand in
developing or even gaining access to a
standardized set of tools this would
make your engagement with entrepreneurs
perhaps somewhat easier perhaps not i
mean i just offer this as an idea to to
think about i realize your discussion is
largely directed kind of internally
people who are members of the department
well i just wanted to share that
observation yeah not it's certainly not
exclusively directed internally I think
that I think that right now where we are
there have to be we could deploy
something that we're already building or
we could come up with some relationship
with somebody who needs something
specific I don't know that were that
we're in a place where we have the
resources to come up with something you
know data resources or something that
somebody might want and see if there's a
market right now but you know so it
would sort of depend on on what the what
the group was and and what they needed
we do have ties and interactions with a
number of the like we're saying we're
focusing on the sort of the
entrepreneurial community this year and
have talked about that it we've never we
haven't gotten to that something
specific yet certainly the discussions
have been that the various approaches
and expertise and informatics is seen of
value but we haven't gotten to
specifically you know it should be this
application
or this kind of data interface or
anything like that yeah add I think you
bring up a really great point which is
you didn't have to be here for very long
before you identify people who were
seeking to do things in this space yeah
and so not only do we have relationships
with many of the technology incubators
startup organizations that are
facilitating startups and
entrepreneurship with in Portland we're
looking kind of at a high level for how
we can get that critical mass and
provide that guidance that you're
talking about i mean if you just look at
what's offered at ohsu in terms of the
seminars that tech transfer puts on the
series that's been running down on the
waterfront run by ron Sakaguchi in the
division of management on
entrepreneurship and some of the things
that we've done is Aaron mention of the
IDL talks and having people in who have
talked about how they've actually done
this themselves there are their
disparate resources and I think one of
the things that we see that we can do is
add value by kind of bringing those
resources together or at least it at
least virtually in some way so that you
can go to one place and see what's going
on and what's available to help all
those things and we're hoping to focus
find a way to focus that energy in the
in the Portland a chai tea space so your
question I will since we're almost at
the hour I will ask the last question
but I'll let you get in the last word ah
well the previous question actually i
think is sort of a nice segue into this
in that especially among startup
companies there's a kind of culture
almost a being of sweat equity and you
know those of us in well actually not it
probably not only in academia but even
in you know more established companies
don't always have the ability to
contribute only sweat equity to projects
and so how does the IDL kind of balance
you know the ability that you know if
you're in a startup company
single-minded thrust you know as opposed
to being part of a large University or a
large company where you're held
accountable by you know people in the
organization above you and how does the
ideal an alarum well this is this is a
really good question because this is
like that you know a hundred thousand
dollar question right as something we're
still working on I think though that
that we're trying to be creative about
mechanisms for doing that I mean part of
this is you know pushing the envelope of
the way the university looks at startups
and entrepreneurship and being part of
that environment and you know can it
support some kind of investment in a
number of different efforts that would
then return some kind of equity over the
long or over the long haul but you know
there's quite there's quite a range of
things to do this you know i mean the
faculty are free you know it's perfectly
acceptable standard practice for faculty
to consult outside of their normal work
hours but i would think that that that
would be a good thing for the department
just isn't in itself and and possibly
lead to more formal relationships and
whatnot so i think there's a whole
spectrum of you know faculty doing
things on the side maybe that are
facilitated from some contacts in the
IDL at the very very light side to you
know the the department or the
university actually having equity and
some some startup company that they
really believe in it they're helping
along and the you know ohsu processes
for making that happen through you know
grants or contracts and tech transfer
and stuff like that is part of the
learnings that we are trying to figure
out now so that's kind of the best
answer I can give you right now we know
it's an issue and we need to approach
this subject and we're pursuing as you
know a number of different creative ways
to look at it so it's just a matter of
finding the right way that that jives
with the you know startup companies and
incubator communities as well as with
with the university